that's right you ready yeah yeah all
right ladies and gentlemen once again
welcome to your favorite podcasts you
know the name you had a woman's bag I
got my man back for that part too
let me see if you got something new on
the singer Mike what you got what you
got no no no no no no you would I know
you and I know no no no no no no no no
no let me get a hit of that go ahead no
no no no no no no no no no no no I said
no I said no I said I said no I said go
get these words in your ear a no a no a
no no no no
yeah
why did you notice thing of Michael's
always here disposal grab before any
reason
don't forget about hangover candle
company it's like one of these they're
not even really a sponsor but to do
about the second I get a drink of one of
these can always post about it so it's
like you know good publicity for me but
the candles actually really dope you
should send somebody in but anyways Ian
Edwards is back in the building
everybody welcome to back to the podcast
in there was part two what I've done but
a time just came out we had a dope show
at a rec room y'all should have been
there we filmed a promo for the rec room
show before this guy is there any part
of this who will see something you could
cut out of this I want to just be doing
your podcast I'm sorry I'm here to
promote shows which I was about to which
entails some be chitinous welcome back
to the program to focus to Ian Edwards
so you back in the building man a lot of
stuff has been going on and in the
comedy world we own last time you were
here we talked all about your origin
story your fake British if your fake
British origin agree I read you that
it's a fake British but night now you
back you strictly a United States
citizen man I know we have it I have it
we haven't even I sat down and talked
about a lot of [ __ ] that's been going on
in the comedy world right now I know you
know but especially you know with the
with the special your special came out
right we promoted your special it was
great
Ian talks is it was on Comedy Central I
think you can still find it on the app
right now right yeah he's on the app and
it's streaming a Comedy Central comment
on Comedy Central calm
make sure you uh make sure you check
that out dude yes holiday time you got
some free time check it out
yeah there's ice you know what's just
coming out December I mean uh this will
be January 17 so you don't know any time
people clamoring for episode will be
like oh I got it in the bank there's not
gonna be a lot of clamorous release oh
just a bonus just might you know what
just me but might be a midweek bonus
episode and I don't know is some patreon
donators put this on there you know by
the way we promote the page thank you
for admitting in the patreon Ian so make
sure you guys have a patreon you can be
a Youtube member or you could be a
patreon member and you don't check that
out there's the link right there I've
done for sure
have you seen if any of these specials
that have come out like have but you saw
them and been like damn that was great
or like hey if any of these specials
moved you or something something
particular about anything out in a
comedy comedy special world that made
you go oh [ __ ] I haven't watched a lot
of specials oh really
like Anna always I'm gonna get to it I'm
gonna get to it
yeah one thing I did get to was the
Chappelle one yeah
and they blew me away I think it's his
best special you think so
yeah yeah I just really liked him and
the way it started he starts telling a
story and then you forget what the whole
thing was about any five minutes later
tells you what he started telling you
you know oh [ __ ] I forgot it's just an
interesting way to start the special and
to make a a societal commentary you know
when he's like I can do two impressions
yeah and you know and then he's talked
and if you talked about Andrew Anthony
Bourdain you know who when everybody
when he died everybody felt it but the
way he introduced Anthony Bourdain
suicide it was he put it on like a
a comedy palatable plate for you to like
he put it in a humorous manner and he
made it was effortless and then just a
whole unfolding of the entire specials
do you think that's important when you
like you know as comedians or for people
out there didn't want to become a comic
is that one of the important things you
think is to take really difficult
subjects and as you say a great way of
saying it is make it palatable and for
people yeah yeah yeah I got a joke I'm
working on now about my mother being a
nanny and how she she worked for this
rich she's a nanny for this rich white
kid and he was so rich I couldn't even
afford to have my own mom like he had
two moms
he's like a reverse Angelina Jolie
situation I had to give this more
[ __ ] my mom it was a cool family and
but it was just funny but when some
people in the audience like you're
laughing because you're comedy and you
have like you know a higher threshold
yes put the truth or when you say it is
in front of people they're like oh oh
that's so sad right and it's like now we
grew up great yeah yeah yeah you're
watching me like yeah you know I mean
like it's like you my name is on the
marquee you came in right and this is a
comedy club these are jokes why are you
taking this my situation that I didn't
take serious so serious yeah that's
that's one that that's something I find
too is it's so strange to me about how
like you know you know they they've
actually come to sit down and listen to
this type of stuff and they have this
sort of like attitude of like like oh no
or they they feel sad for the imaginary
people sometimes that we're talking
about no and I mean like I like I had
this thing about like you know if I'm a
no-legged guy was delivering your
groceries just in the middle of a whole
story you know and then the way they
respond I'm like okay I know you guys
feel bad for the imaginary one like a
guy but it's like pay attention to
what's happening in this situation I
mean society's weird man about that kind
of stuff but like I've watched a few
specials I agree with you on the
Chappelle's brush I've talked about it
on the podcast already but I love
my favorite part about the Chappelle
special was how comfortable he was yeah
he's always comfortable but this one was
something I think that in a combination
of the five specials like you know I
don't know if he would let's say if this
was the first one he might not have been
as comfortable yeah you know just just
because and then we might not have
perceived it the same way if it was safe
the first you could have flipped any of
them but about but a little something
about there was something about his the
confidence level he had about like like
I'm gonna talk about these things cuz
I'm the only one they can he had like a
certain swagger about it and the
comfortableness that i thought it really
made me think about all the things I'm
doing after that I was like oh man I
gotta get that comfortable I always
think I'm comfortable and I was like not
like that though well this is funny
because a few years ago there was a set
of Chappell's that he did at the comic
strip in New York online and then you
know I've seen day before in the club do
like three four I was going into six
hours and and I'm kind of like you watch
it and you watch it but then there's the
comic strip one he's all he's and he
does the same thing he's taken a lot of
questions you don't know he doesn't know
what the questions are gonna be so then
you don't know if you're gonna from my
perspective you don't know what the
question is gonna be so if you're gonna
be able to come up with a funny answer
right and then like you hate silence
sometimes you know because you feel like
you're not doing your job
but yeah he was completely comfortable
with that and I was like man he's gotta
be the most composed comfortable comic
of all time better than everybody so
just that let me know that I wasn't
comfortable but yeah he was comfortable
in this one he's just but I guess he
does all those sets where he's just
smoking on stage and he's taking
questions and there's a lot of things to
learn throughout a set but he's been
practicing being comfortable with all
these long sets taking questions and
even if some people aren't happy he's
comfortable well you could tell that he
revels in people's unhappiness though
like I think that he's like tripled down
on the transgender topic right and it's
like he's like just embraced
it's like I'm gonna be the guy that
talks about this it's almost like his
hot pockets like Jim Gaffigan like
transgender is oh sure pills hot pocket
so they're you know and then just the
way he talks about it's like at this
point you're just like uh you know the
people that hate him he's just beating
him down but now they just have to
listen and be like okay now what right
and then even the way he told that story
like with me did a show with him and
Rogan we were we for Tacoma Tacoma Dome
it's like 20,000 people [ __ ] and right
we all did great but to see him that the
tell that joke because it's a story it's
a bit you know and a comic is good when
he makes people laugh like we all made
people that yeah but when you like relax
and take it down like 20,000 people to
make them just listen yeah and then
laugh when you want them to laugh and
then just listen like he's comfortable
so then 20,000 people are you amazing
unanimously comfortable and that was
crazy to watch I like that I like that
myself even even myself I like when the
crowd is completely silent right like
they're just like waiting for you to
like what are you gonna say next
I think that's a that's a great thing
and it's like but it's like although all
these other I don't know man [ __ ] the
[ __ ] is it is it is a great thing
because there's a comic your toward yet
we're taught or trained you gotta kill
Bam Bam Bam go hard have them rolling
all the way through and a lot of people
can even bad comics can do that yeah but
you gotta be good to be like make
everybody silent but but just into you
throughout the silence yeah that's a
form of like mastery yeah man yeah he's
mastered it yeah I think the weird
you're special I saw was low real
special you would tell me about a you
gotta watch it just we it was just weird
I just I just think like you know our
buddy Jerrod he just loves
unconventional right
his production company should just be
unconventional [ __ ] that should
be the name of it well if he [ __ ] with
a 24 all this [ __ ] is on called as
unconventional yeah it just I just was
like I was like wow this is like but
it's like sometimes I don't know if like
when people do say unconventional things
like is it like are we does that become
a set-piece
into special so it's like two schools of
thought like you just want people just
to ignore everything around it and they
just see this person doing the jokes or
is the whole thing a piece of work you
know what do you think well I've learned
I had something to say it's like so I
heard I didn't see the special yet so I
heard in the special starts out in the
daytime yeah and then it turns to night
because they did a gym yeah there's like
a big window it's a beautiful shot right
you don't I mean it's a beautiful shot
in this like little shaped like an
airplane hangar you know so there's like
this big window glass and he's like in a
inner sort of in the round you know I
mean so there's people behind him and
there's a big crowd in front of them and
then they go in the windows to the side
so it's like they see yeah so you know
the special started but it's like so all
that kind of stuff you know it's like if
you notice that kind of stuff so you can
see time passing and to me is like you
know there's a lot of things there's a
lot of great art in history movies
whatever that mistakes were made
right but those mistakes I'll just be
like oh that mistake worked out as a
thing oh right you know and then I so I
don't know if that was a mistake or it
was done on purpose I also if it was
done on purpose there's also the point
that everybody's gonna remember it
started at 9:00 in the daytime and
transitioned into nighttime for a comedy
special nobody's ever seen that yeah
yeah geez so yeah and then you know I
remember like watching like old MTV
documentaries when they to talk about
how they were invented or how they and
the shaky-cam [ __ ] yeah the jump cuts
which when I was taught in film school
you know supposed to jump cut take
things from a different angle so you can
cut from one thing to the other
but MTV broke all those rules and those
things became like normal yeah so I got
it so you know this is could be where
we're at I mean obviously I mean I just
I just think that with the with the
watering down of the art form in terms
of like just you know it's just so much
content it's just like there's so many
specials outs so much time so it's like
you know no people not gonna have time
to see my special on Comedy Central this
is [ __ ]
which Ian talks which is hot here yeah
I'm really worried people are not gonna
get a chance it's well me that's like
again you made you put that content out
are you ready for some new content I
mean yeah you know that's that's what
time it is yeah yeah I'm also thinking
like sometimes like you know how you
like accumulate a bunch of bits and so
now I'm feeling like okay so here's some
bits I have so now I have to start
categorizing like these are okay that I
want to put something together that I
put out on my YouTube channel and then
the other ones are like okay I'm gonna
save these because I feel like things
are strong for if I do another special
so now I'm starting cuz you have like
especially like current you know yeah
you know I mean like if you have like
let's say you have Trump stuff right now
or whatever he might be out of office in
you know when by the time you tape a
special and it comes out and then what's
that gonna be so it's like maybe that
stuff's for like the you know put that
on the internet right now yeah you know
so I don't I'm starting to think about
it like that at this point cuz like I
just think people like consuming the
stand-up content so it's like but do you
think that my water down even the
stand-up you know cause it's like if you
go well I could just go watch all this
stand-up you know just YouTube
somebody's stand-up you know that gonna
be better than they're like you know the
special or is it gonna be just be all
one thing uh my initial instinct is like
to worry about [ __ ] being watered down
but then you know just thinking about it
just a second further it's just like and
I'm just just not gonna give a [ __ ]
about it I'm just gonna focus on my [ __ ]
and some people everybody has the way
that they wanted
do their thing yeah I just got to do my
thing the way I want to do my thing and
then there's stuff to learn from the way
he's other people do it you know like I
definitely feel like I need to put out
more content that's right well I do one
way of doing this by doing the roommates
thing which is great guys make sure you
check out this little web series that
Ian's doing on this on his Instagram and
it's also gonna be on the youtubes on
YouTube's on YouTube now goo which is
great it's called roommates and it's
really some funny sketches from the
minds of Ian Edwards and his buddy Paul
like it's really funny so but I could
see this what I'm saying it's like it's
a way like we're putting this even when
you do a podcast those like look at the
effort I put into it I got eyes all over
the place that could electrocute us all
I fixed the wire situation cuz you piece
of [ __ ] I got these wires going in here
I'm gonna get a rug right here so you
don't see these eager that's good I feel
like I see more wires but it's cool
don't see this glass of water don't
spill electrocution Christmas oh my god
maybe maybe feel soccer podcasts have
more wire you got more wires than my
podcast got listeners you know I know
you know just a different subject I was
just thinking about like it's like we've
been around for a while now I think
we've known each other over 10 years
yeah yeah you know and that's I was once
I was looking on Instagram the other day
and I'm looking I'm seeing like so like
chicks that I was trying to talk to 10
years ago they on Instagram and I'm
looking at them now and they got their
kids and husband and I'm like this chick
was a huh you know they say you can't
make a hoe a housewife on Instagram you
totally can it's funny to see the chant
you know this like that [ __ ] like to
change have you ever looked on Instagram
I've been like this chick is respectable
now or like even news it's not just
women it's like you know if I see a dude
on my friend of mine who I know his
Dean's were all fired ten years ago and
now all of a sudden he got a three year
old
I mean people are young they got
yearnings and also I think at some point
the biological clock takes over yeah and
like and they you have to make a
decision and just maybe some nature [ __ ]
and some instinctual [ __ ] I think that's
never changed but what I'm saying is
isn't it weird how weird ah cumin ting
it now like it's like we're the
transitions from yeah come from from
hole to mother yeah like a good book
from hold a mother I just mean you have
to learn all that [ __ ] and be like be a
hole whether you're a man or a woman so
later on when your kids are growing up
and they trying to pull these tricks on
you you feel like [ __ ] I did
that but what do you okay before like
parents so like parents had like this
aura of like we never did anything wrong
and liar but now you'll get your kids
gonna be like my isn't that you some of
them are doing male and female are doing
whole [ __ ] while they got kids yeah yeah
Wow and posting it on Instagram oh well
this kid's parents always think kids
don't understand [ __ ] yeah yeah they
always think that's do wrong kids kids
pick up an absorb way more than you
think we just think that they don't know
anything because we just want to say
what we want to say without being
feeling having a guilty conscience about
saying it yeah
but they know I remember trying to have
sex with this girl in England right so I
was there to do some shows I was
attracted to her we ran into each other
in town in Birmingham and she's like
come over later right so I was like I
like her but I don't know if I'm gonna
try to have sex with her I'm gonna just
go over there let me just rephrase it
yeah I might just go over there and hang
out with her but no intention was to go
to go to see what I wanted to get some
[ __ ] no I didn't have anything on a
dollar gamble
and I was I was already there cause this
is my explanation of how it is like our
parents kids know right so that's like
let me go over here so I go over here
we're hanging out and a son share that
he was maybe like maybe three or two or
maybe a little older this [ __ ]
wouldn't go to bed and he wasn't excited
about company he knew that I might want
to [ __ ] his mom to go to bed so this kid
I didn't even know what I wasn't even
sure what I wanted to do right but he
was sure when I wanted to do like he
knew before I did he was letting you
know what you gonna do and he stayed up
till 4:00 in the morning he wore me out
and I left and he's refused to go to
sleep like she had to keep on attention
we just hung out talking it would've
been great anyway she was like it'll be
great if that keep their mom was like
let me go get him some milk or something
and then the kid just look at you like
you ain't volume mama
basically what he did for six hours like
kids know about sex
somehow he couldn't even speak but he's
like there to prevent something from
happening I remember you know I look
back on like you think I look back on
when my mom was a certain age and single
and had me and I can remember now I
remember us you know certain situations
you know what I mean where I'm thinking
to myself oh I asked what I do was over
I think we know something's up but like
I don't know if necessarily it's like
but I think because of the I don't know
who I would have been if I would I wish
can you imagine if we had the internet
at art when we were like in high school
or I don't know if my I think my I'm
trying to think how my life would have
change or what how would have been
different I think you know maybe I would
have been more experimental or I would
have been more maybe I'll have known
more people or I just don't know I just
feel like
what is the effect that this has had
like on this new generation cuz like I'm
saying like you can watch we're tracking
everything like how are you gonna tell
your kids to not do a certain thing and
then like you you have on your Instagram
you know bikini pictures or their
there's their own because there's dad
with like you know I know but if you
tell him if you a dad are you telling
your daughter like yeah I don't think
you should be wearing that when you go
to this thing you know make sure you
know and then here's your mom and dad
like you're they out at a you know at a
at a rave you know clearly drinking and
smoking and like you know just it's
gonna be harder to like it's gonna be
harder to like tell kids coming up like
you know just blindly be like you should
never do this you should never do that
and drugs are bad and don't drink and be
respectful of your body and all this
kind of stuff when you have proof that
you never were I mean it's not that they
did but who says it's proof that they
never were that's just because they were
in a bikini I'm not dude listen I agree
with you I'm not disagreement I'm not
saying to be I'm saying you know how
parents are you know what people get
real whoa I know how to get forty I know
I love saying our parents were but I
don't parents have changed they'd like a
lot more open I see
I've seen the harichandra Hollywood
Boulevard with their kids their young
daughters in short shorts and I'm like
she's like back in the day a kid would
have to hide that outfit from their
parents to wear it enough now they like
with them so I think like the way people
have parented has changed but I don't
know however the kids is watching people
I feel I feel they have to change I
think because it yeah because of the
useful phrase I was at Santa Monica and
I was walking behind his family and I
said with the mom and the daughter and
the daughter she must have been I'm not
obviously young no not 18 right and her
booty was just chicks were looking at
I'm like you should have went to excuse
me yeah
hey I'm trying to walk and not go to
jail hey dude
just for me you know it's like a week
cuz in now I'm the pervert you ever seen
I'm I'm the pervert because cuz you
don't even know sometimes you just walk
in and these young girls they don't even
look
they don't look their age oh I don't
even know what that means anymore no no
I mean I don't know what it means
anymore cuz you look yet you just have
to be like if somebody looks too young
don't ask me for direction yeah don't
don't don't yell fire cuz you're gonna
burn do you have I need you to sign this
consent form for me to put you out of
fire to tuck and roll you yeah yeah man
it's crazy but I just it's funny just
like I like seeing somebody like Will
Smith on on the Internet
I like seeing him anon on Instagram it's
a that's uh that's funny it's weird to
see someone so famous and then he really
humanizes himself you know
cuz you see him with his family or he'll
be like you know he's such also an
intense [ __ ] did you ever been
on his Instagram yeah so that's when
he's just talking about something or
he's trying to be a motivational you're
just like damn just why he made it you
know I love seeing like his watching his
family that they're so open because they
got like she got her show on Facebook
which she was open about yeah well she's
open and he's on Instagram open and
they're just talking about their kids
and then you finding out all this weird
[ __ ] about them you know it is like damn
I was tell you just the other day I read
this thing about like how they had an
open marriage at one time they did yeah
I think they were yet I think they were
like he was Mary Jane she said it ah I
think she said I don't know if it's not
cheating if he's allowed right right
right
he's allowed to go under so go walkabout
yeah what yeah and then I thought we'll
damn I think so let us regular dudes you
say that to your girl like we know Will
Smith and I wait you mean Will Smith so
say but I also think Jada is by
- so that's that's kind of opens that up
- but imagine that the punishment for
not being Will Smith is one [ __ ] mayor
well the world has been under that
punishment for a long that's gonna be in
the wedding vows that you are not Will
Smith you have a one [ __ ] marriage like
what this is outrageous but it's a lot
of people a lot of a lot of marriages
have a one vagina minimum yeah maximum
we not evolved yet let's see their
marriages thriving yeah you know who has
a fun marriage to watch on Instagram
who's a David Arnold oh man
dude I hit him up and I said it dude
just put some cameras on your house good
job I don't have a family but that's
that's a family I want yeah yeah I think
he's in a tar I think he's actually in
talks with like a network or something
like that
I mean it's his daughter's then D'Amato
Dulli just the way they always survive
and it's great and it feels like they
get to say the things that regular
couples can't say to each other
and they get to joke about it and
instead of having like all this
resentment like that should have built
up bright side and they get to joke it
out and be a family I have fun I've had
David all on the podcast Dave Arnold
David he doesn't be calling Dave anymore
so David Arnold's been on the podcast
you should follow his Instagram because
it is it is funny he just he's always
recording him and his wife and it's yeah
just doing stuff I know that's what the
internet it's just interesting like
imagine you and a it's like so you could
be fighting with your wife mm-hmm you
could be like why can't we be like this
couple yeah yeah yeah like we're not
even fake cuz like look this is real yes
the husband holding the camera Oh baby
oh maybe that's the device like the
cameras like the therapist that makes
everybody argue on their best behavior
yeah you know what I mean so you get to
say what you really want to say and I
guess say what I'm really gonna say but
we have to say it in in a humane tone to
each other so that we can get it out
which is what a lot of couples need and
also grow yeah you know to me maybe the
camera is like a great maybe therapy is
about to go out of business if you know
cuz you know you're not gonna like yell
like a [ __ ] animal when you're
holding your own camera you know I tried
out what you want to say I tried web
therapy cuz my therapist that I was
going to kind of semi-retired and she
went into like web therapy and it's we
went into lazy lazy yeah yeah lazy get
your money though yeah I just I just
didn't like it but I didn't give it its
due though cuz I'm in web therapy now
but see I just don't have a girlfriend
to be honest yeah I got a girlfriend so
I'm just a side note I just like I just
had to go on Instagram here's the thing
when you in a relationship okay when you
we have this Instagram and we act a
certain way I look on the Instagram I go
oh that's that's that girl's attractive
oh nice outfit like like like like like
like but what you what you don't realize
is your significant other might be like
why are you liking all these ghost
pictures I like a lot of [ __ ] I like
cars and I like girls like if somebody
got a great outfit on or they just look
good they worked on their body male or
female yeah oh I'll give them their
props it doesn't mean I know but it
doesn't mean it doesn't feel like just
some people doesn't right it's a big
deal so I'm with you every every day how
am i how am i [ __ ] these people so I
just made a choice so just I'm not
liking pictures anymore yeah but now
it'll get rid of the thing you just
don't matter though because here's how
it makes it worse this is nothing maybe
get rid of so like let's get rid of it
let's say I mean you we're friends and
then we have somebody else we're friends
with so because we're friends if I like
this picture and let's say we're we have
a lot of interaction with each other
when you go to this it shows on the
bottom it says
you know the you know says who likes it
the first name to come up is gonna be
Ian Edwards Eric Griffin because because
we're friends
so that's what was happening like we
our mutual friends and I just call me
and say hey man could you like this
picture for me just send me the list I
like him through you know what it really
isn't a big deal it's not worth fighting
over because I just go who cares if I
like it I like it in my head I don't
need to like like you know I just like
we never like we live a life like no you
know we don't like you know when you go
online and you look at a porno you don't
go that's oh you bookmark it unless
spectable way that's what I'm saying so
I just now I just got boom that's all I
said you know what I just I'm not a new
thing I'm back in it I'm back with my
girl and I'm just I'm approaching it
differently I wanted to work I wanted to
like I want to do all the things that I
need to do but like I'm saying when I
the web therapy I didn't give it its due
because the first time I did I was
laying in bed with my laptop on my lap
you know yes I did but what was
happening was I found myself being
distracted I was looking at emails and I
was like you know to me so I said I
didn't do it again but I want to do it
again but don't worry your therapist was
looking at emails - I know what I want
to do is I want to put you need to if
you need to put the laptop on your
kitchen table or something and actually
sit back like as if you're going into an
office now you'll have them all like or
cinema dress up take a shower but it you
know me I think you got to do all the
things that you got to do that you cuz I
enjoy the act of going to therapy
I enjoyed the like you know I used to be
dentistry so I will walk sometimes to
school and you walk you clear your head
and you sit there you really like
intellectualize with this person that's
not what I liked about it is like being
able to talk about really high level
concepts about how I felt about things
with somebody that's not gonna judge me
no oh I don't have to wait if they get
it or not no you know that's one of the
things I think is important about
therapy yeah you know it's nice oh
you're not in couple therapy you're just
in therapy yeah I was just going like
just for myself to deal with my boundary
issues and things like that I think
that's such a big I think boundaries are
such a big thing that we have trouble
with it's like when somebody asks you
for money like I saw Marcellus Wiley on
speaker
he says he'll be tossed Harvard or one
of those he went to he went to Ivy
League he went to an Ivy League school
so he's real smart intellectual do but
he talked he said just on the shucks I
watch the show religiously and he was
like you know what people ask you for
money you have to be able to say no
mm-hmm but the next step is you have to
say no without guilt
no and that's an important boundary you
know cuz sometimes people ask you for
money yeah when you when you're a
celebrity and [ __ ] like that and the
markets probably played football he's on
call he yeah so family members are gonna
hit him up family no well yeah could you
make yourself unapproachable this is why
don't need therapy for boundaries you
got other you got other issues hey I can
working on those but but no for no money
first yeah my ship was boundaries just
about just with people you know I found
myself always like you know being around
people who always need help you know
emotionally oh yeah you know financially
emotionally you know yeah so I find
myself being like what is this you know
you have to be able to just be like you
know cut it off and one time I should
have got it and got some money fine now
it's too late now
boundaries damn it's like when you go to
like you know it's like there's another
thing I like about therapy hmm you go
and then when the hours up okay I don't
care how deep it is I don't care what's
happening your therapist is like okay I
mean are you cold blooded it was about
as I was about to solve the whole thing
here and you talk for real well who's
that what the next person want to talk
about yeah man it was like you ever be
like hey man let's be honest don't you
have the best conversations with me
completely why would you want to cut
this off if you want to demote yourself
and go talk to somebody with a less
higher you know I made you laugh and you
know [ __ ] you I feel but you know but it
taught me is that and there is a time
limit to things
yeah you know so even when so yeah it
teaches me like even in conversations we
could be out we don't got to talk all
night it can get to a point where it's
like all right that was cool I'll see
you next time
you know just I
I just feel like boundaries are an
important thing man and I'm dealing with
your guilt that'll be great in a
relationship like we got half hour to
talk about this yeah and we're not going
past it I think you should you're not
taking this into the car yeah to the
dinner table to the movies this is it
one thing my therapist had told me about
like when you're fighting is to like
like she is greater she said every bad
thing you do or say in a relationship in
in a fight and try to do five good
things you know so and it's like that's
the ratio to make yourself feel better
and my girl she's great about like
wanting a hug in the middle of a fight
oh yeah and it's like you feel about
wanting to [ __ ] in the middle of a fight
well that's but that's where it ends
that's right that's already fight the
[ __ ] these therapy if you like you don't
want to have drug sex you could have
like six fights exes listen I'm coming
over to start a fight and you know what
target is this dizzy I don't like you
know what I don't like fight I don't
like fighting no I don't like fighting I
don't actually I don't I'm not I think
there's a problem when you to make up
you have to have sex because for men to
me I feel like it anchors something bad
about having sex with this person if we
have to like so we've we fought we
fought we because they think that like
when we're having sex now it means I
forgive you and I can't let no I'm hate
[ __ ] you some some people might want
to hate yeah yeah that's bad because
that's how they associate like love you
disassociate yourself so you have to
find a way to be adventurous and you
know but I like to hug like I was trying
to say is like it's like your body is
you're so mad are you still like
stubborn about this feeling it but when
you hug this person it what's so hard to
be mad at somebody you hug it but what
what are people fighting about dude it's
that's the but that's why that's the
whole test the whole thing usually is
about to me
people this is what I feel like happens
in fights especially in relationships is
you have a topic that you want to fight
about right mm-hmm and then why are you
fighting about instantly the fight
becomes about how you're fighting about
this thing because that's what usually
happens like a lot of times in the fight
a girl say like don't talk to me like
that now it's not even about the thing
as cheating that she did that's cheating
you know you know I'm talking in the
same tone we're both talk you're talking
to me
we're fighting you know we're trying not
to fight what we're fighting so it's not
about that that's not gonna help this it
you ask what evens your cheating but
that's what happens you know like you're
in the middle of the fighter you say
something you don't mean or you say
something and then now it becomes like
we've forgotten why we talked about this
initial thing in the first place we've
lost sight oh yeah but that's even the
initial I mean like some things are
pretty straightforward and clear cut you
know it's a lot of arguments like like
even I just think the way we just love
the way we were trained to loved by
movies by our parents by life it's just
wrong period like household elaborate
just like in my last relationship right
so I would you know I think when a guy
really loves a girl he does a lot of
things to make the girl happy you know
what I mean go take her places go places
do things and then I think I wanted to
return I'm like I'd like to see her
happy cuz it made me feel like she loved
me and then Dennis and then and then it
questions do I love myself enough to I
need to feel this from this person you
know what I mean
you know it's funny you talking about
this again because I was talking about
the same kind of thing with Joshua if I
had just had Josh wolf on my mom cast
and I was talking about the love
language test have you ever taken a love
language test no I think you should it's
a fascinating test because not just a
bit of results but because of the
questions they asked to get to these
results huh it really says a lot about
who you are just like it's like what
like a question might be like
when you come home do you want to be
left alone for a minute don't you want
but those are the kind of things that
leads you to and it lead you to like so
it's like acts of service is one of them
physical touch receiving gifts let me
get the other ones only get the other
ones and so what up cuz cuz what you
just said something right now I thought
was of it is very fascinating to like to
figure out like what actually makes you
tick like what are the things okay so
here they are one of them okay so acts
of service physical touch words of
affirmation and quality time and
receiving gifts those are the primary
love languages I know
so like understanding the love languages
will make you help you understand like
why you respond to certain things and
you know so it's like so for you it
might be like word like it could be
words of affirmation really get you
going you know but like cuz like mine my
first one is acts of service so it's
like I like ya take me to the airport
you know or I like action I don't like
words like so that so that's that you
guys I'm from New York and so just like
as a person I know when I do something
for somebody especially if I go out of
my way to do it is because the way I
feel about them you can't tell me you
feel this way about me but never do
anything okay but I'll show it but what
I'm saying is because it's easy to talk
but that's what people say pimps talk I
know but see is that for you that means
that again words of affirmation is gonna
be on the bottom
yeah but for someone else it might be at
the top yeah and knowing that it helps
to have a better understanding of your
partner it's just one tool I'm saying no
no no I'm not against it yeah I talk
about this a lot because I feel like
it's important to for people to
understand and like I say that's the
test itself just the questions and how
you but I also mentioned this to my ex
to it's like any man this these are
words anybody can say these words
but another you know what you're talking
about right now which i think is
important is is like let's say words of
affirmation on the bottom for you but
there at the top for her understanding
that it's not at the top for you is
important to know because sometimes we
think what we think what we how we
receive love we think that that's how
everyone enjoys receiving love and they
don't not everybody feels the same way
but it's hard for us to understand that
because we're like crazy that someone
wants words over actions of love I know
I I understand that but there are people
that like it like like receiving gifts
is another one that if it's high on
someone's list for me I remember [ __ ]
yeah yeah and it's not gifts it's just
like it's like you can well and it's not
just actions like you can't say one
thing and your actions are the opposite
of course of course because then your
words have no value and it's like that's
just that's why words are cheating you
know that you're just I just I just
you just phoning it in verbally I
understand you feel that way but for
some people getting that hearing that
means a lot to them like healing the
things which is funny but I'll do both
know I catch you I'm not again we're not
we're speaking the same language no [ __ ]
that [ __ ] man the argument I know but
I'm just saying like don't talk to me
that way what I'm just saying like the
gifts one is like a big one my girls
like that she likes to receive gifts so
but but but I'm talking about it's not
like it sounds it's not like oh a
diamond necklace I right I'm talking
about like it could be a ten dollar gift
certificate to like her favorite coffee
place just that act of that it's like oh
you know it's doesn't it but anyway the
point is the the love languages and
taking the test it really like I'm gonna
have one of my buddies come on I
actually do two tests with him I want
him to see the results cuz then you'd be
surprised you get these results you like
him I didn't realize that that was so
important to me based off my answer yeah
you know but again just getting back to
it like you know relationships so just
you know I just think
we have to be way more thoughtful now
because all our business is on the phone
it's all in our profiles and apps and
and now we have like a history like this
is new it's one thing to be like you're
on the internet for a couple of years
but we we've been at it at since the
impetus of the [ __ ] like we from the
start so now I look back and you know
what in like Facebook or so I'm gonna
tell you you've been on since 2001 or
whatever does like that when you
actually start to go back and look
you're like damn I've done a lot of
things I've seen a lot of stuff I've
taken pictures with a lot of people so I
don't go back but sometime now they're
doing this thing where they go this is
you six years ago this happen or those
yeah I hate especially when it's a
picture with somebody you like I don't
even like that [ __ ] Facebook if
you know me so well
crop the personnel before you post this
is you from six years ago Facebook knows
when he cropped her out yeah it's been
Facebook date they I'm so off of it I
haven't even I don't even use it that
much if I wasn't an entertainment I
wouldn't go on it at all I just go to my
page to like promote things or whatever
like that but I don't use it for what I
used to use it for them it just it's
just lost it's like I mean they
throttling everything and they they make
it hard for you to reach the people who
follow you anywhere but who are your
friends and Instagram is doing the same
thing to and they can deny it as much as
they want but it's definitely all the
posts are being throttled and and people
are gonna leave and go somewhere else
yeah because yeah so I can't get to
these people have decided they like me
mm-hmm and you're now stopped because
they like me you're stopping it so you
can monetize it so I have to pay I have
to pay so the people who like me can see
my post on your platform and they came
on the platform to see me and and you're
making us both work yeah it sucks
I used to be more yeah you should be
more open and free yeah I wish it would
just get back that's what we liked about
it well let's get on this topic if you
put my information and stuff on it I was
off of Facebook when they had this thing
where you know somebody would send you a
friend request and then and then you
would be like you would be like you want
to say no and it's not an option it says
not now not know that's like Facebook
going let's not make any hasty decision
let's circle back to this you know it's
so like you ever think about like it's
so hard to remove someone from your life
now like it's so hard to like we let's
say we have a falling out and so now I
gotta like I gotta move on my phone I
got it like a block you on Instagram
block you on Twitter block you on
Facebook block you won't tik-tok block
you on snapchat you know I gotta go with
my email but you don't block me on
tick-tock it's like there's no you you
actually can't block anybody it's like
being in a room with someone and trying
to ignore them and it's just almost
impossible I've had to do it there's
somebody in my life I was like I don't
want to ever talk to this [ __ ]
again oh like ever again I don't you
know don't care this [ __ ] live
or die know you know and it's like you
go damn you really mean to your mom you
know I gotta like it's like even with
email used to like I had to go into my
email server and be like when emails
come from this address don't even how do
you want us cuz my thing is I don't even
want to see it and what I hate about
blocking let's see you block somebody on
Instagram I hate that the list the
blocked people list is there cuz then
they're there I want to just remove I
wanna this should be like a explode
button and this person is just removed
from your life but you can't even find
their profile anymore you can't you know
what I'm saying like you'd have to I
mean you can murder them they won't post
anymore I don't know but it's still
there so I don't know how to I gotta
figure out how to just be like I need
you out mm-hmm you've never you never
had that you never wanted to just you
just you just you have a cool demeanor
so you don't even don't even bug you
there's there's people I just like but
they're not like like just people who
like try to what are they
trolls yeah yeah yeah but nobody really
close
yeah well that's good for you man yeah
I've always found you to be like you
just have an even keel personality that
even when you really mad at somebody you
still have the same demeanor and that's
a testament to your personality so I
wish I was well I'm Way too volatile and
emotional I have these highs and lows of
like you know it's nothing wrong with
that I like that but I just I know how
and I get angry sometimes too but I
think most most of that stuff that you
describe about you just happens in a
relationship yeah yeah yeah for me you
know what I mean but I got more even
keel just outer ones there's just too
much like we're talking about love and
probably the way I love drawing or just
people peerages it's just so much at
stake because when I'm so low like
there's nothing at stake I know what I'm
gonna do yeah I know how I'm gonna do it
you know where I know go and I'm gonna
do I know how to take care of me
emotionally but when I'm open and
attached to someone then like how they
feel can make me feel and I want then to
feel good so I can feel good so this
it's like or even the act even the act
of having to worry about somebody else's
violence can be cumbersome or what
they're gonna do is it's it's a it's
you're connected so I'm not even sure if
that's the way we're supposed to love
that's the thing I'm questioning because
how can you how do we love right so that
people don't and you know it's and then
some people have kids with people and
some people have like so many
connections to people in so many
different ways when they're in a
relationship how do you it's just so
tough to not be emotional I totally
agree with you
like if 50% of marriages fail and we've
been in so many relationships in our
life that just for whatever reason it
just didn't work out like to me the odds
just seemed that this ain't right like
just like the proper way to do it but
totally agree with you somebody you know
but I do know one thing from like I was
like what's the one I was after my last
relationship I was talk to this girl
that we
I thought we were dating right what's
the purpose of a relation the purpose of
a relationship is to make you yourself a
better person through the relationship
because you have to be honest with this
person you know what I mean do you I
mean to the point where you'll know if
this person is really the person you're
supposed to be with yeah you know what I
mean like if you like something and you
never tell them because you oh you think
they'll be offended by it or not into
you by it
and then you hold this thing back and
you with this person you're kind of
gonna resent this person you know what I
mean or you'll never be was gonna be
free and be yourself around this person
but if you tell them even if they don't
accept it at first maybe they'll accept
it later maybe they'll never accept it
but then you'll know if this person is
supposed to really be your person so I
know if I work it's I mean you doing
work right now you're going to therapy I
know my [ __ ] I know my body it'll just
live in his work right but I've never
met a person that's been in a marriage
that said that it was easy I know I know
I mean like but but it's a Huth it's
always like this - though it's a lot of
work marriages all my married friends so
when people but that one thing it does
tell me though is that the upside
obviously it's worth it because they
make it because but I know but I mean if
they don't make it even oh but I'm
saying it's like if the downside can
make you go who this is but but
obviously the upside is like you know
maybe because a lot of people committed
to the Third Reich till the end as I
wasn't worth it so being married is like
being a Nazi no I'm just saying people
make bad commitments and because they
committed to it they they keep trying to
make it work you know what I mean
I think some people get interesting I
think when you're young you get into
relationships because they made a speech
in front of a bunch of people and then
like I so got to make this work Wow
maybe all the commitment all the bank
account stuff all the mm-hmm
no but I think when you're young you
just get into relationship a lot of
times I think it's because you just want
to have sex with someone safely
not to and that's not a great reason
let's not be in a relationship for life
with someone yeah yeah it's not the best
reason it's not gonna I think that's one
of the reasons yeah I mean I think that
that's you know you just go and a part
of that is like religion you know is a
part of marriage right yes and then
those are one of the rules of religion
so this marriage you funneled into
relation Eric yeah so Will Smith right
yeah whatever religion he's a part of us
just join that one no I swear to what it
what are the vows love honor respect
love honor respect you know Will Smith
way till death do us part we start our
own religion this convinced the Will
Smith way yeah Will Smith vows you want
the Will Smith out regular [ __ ]
man getting the regular box god I do
drool a ships are just absolutely tough
and then like but there is tough as we
there's a lot of think about
relationships the good thing is we have
these fears and these fears are about us
and you have to like let go you know
what I mean yes I told you we have to
live self work if you have to work on
you if you can recognize your problem in
this volatile relationship people forget
that you're a part of it it's a wee
situation right but but there's also the
other part of it there's a line to of
how much letting go are you letting go
the other person ain't lettin go to and
you have to recognize if they're not or
ever not gonna let go and if this is not
fair you know
today you'd be like alright so is its it
really taps into your instincts your
god-given instincts as a human being for
you to know how far to let go if they're
letting go and to guess if they're the
type of person to let go of this you you
really have to tap like everything we're
doing in life makes you it should force
you internally inside like we're in this
you talking about social media and just
all this information on the computer and
sometimes you don't know which side is
right or left like should I eat meat or
should I not eat meat like this thing's
for and against it it's being a vegan
good or not being a vegan like what is
you telling you instinctually yeah are
you trying to tap into you on the inside
and figure this out they said of getting
all this outside information at a
certain point you got enough outside
information and go inside and figure
this [ __ ] out because the answers of it
the answers are there III I completely
agree with you I mean but that's this is
all about self work there's a self work
you know working what what are you doing
the best you could do
are you achieving your highest level
that that's possible and like you said
you know you take all the information
that you can and then at some point
though you have to just figure it out on
your own yeah and that's just you know I
think that comes with age I just I just
feel like I'm at a point now where I'm
starting to be like oh here's my I'm I'm
I can I see my fault in know some
situations that I've had and I'm trying
to correct that right you know I mean
all works in progress except me work in
progress work I don't know if this was a
new episode or if this was a bonus
episode in a week or whatever it is I
always enjoy talking to my buddy here in
err word saying hey fam yeah Ian talks
special you can still find it on the
Comedy Central app or the on-demand on
Comedy Central probably so check that
out check out roommates on Ian Edwards
Instagram in average comic when it was
comic you never call the animal inches
and links to download so check that out
is very funny and look at the me and Ian
and I've decided we're gonna try to go
out do some dance all over the country
some places we're gonna do it together
and so we're gonna so make sure you look
on both our websites I'm Eric our friend
calm and you know but always I'll always
let you know but let you know so look
out for that on our instagrams and stuff
because we just feel like you know what
let's
let's go out and like you know fight on
some spots
do some shows I seem up and build in the
house yes we trying to team up and so
there it is right there so if you want
to come see us do comedy we just did a
show at the rec room
we either just did a show or we about to
do a show December 21st
so it either like I said either just did
it oh we about to do I missed it you may
have missed me man yeah it [ __ ] up you
may have missed it you should've snuck
in y'all may have missed out this
episode out of Eric's computer before he
posted it before the show so I'll keep
you guys posted on that but anyways this
has been Ian Edwards make sure you
subscribe share and thanks for listening
to rhythm with Griffin and I appreciate
you guys and I'll see you next week
my pleasure yeah